Thanksgiving is a time to be grateful
for what we have and gather with loved
ones but can also be pretty overwhelming
especially for Mom if she's doing most
of the heavy lifting for the holiday
parenting expert life coach and Mom of
seven Hannah Keeley is here with me to
help all moms ditch the stress and enjoy
themselves good morning Hannah nice to
meet you horny hard to believe hope for
having a stress-free Thanksgiving I
can't believe you're a mom of seven and
you told me your oldest is almost 30 so
wow you must have a houseful for
Thanksgiving
we do and it's so much fun and I'm
telling you the biggest thing that
stands in the way of moms having an
enjoyable restful Thanksgiving is two
words unrealistic expectations
well you've got some great tips and I
read through them and I love the first
one the first one is turkey or maybe
take out you could design something
who's truly creative like one time you
know we we ordered takeout another time
you know someone had a pizza and we it
was it's just fun when you allow like I
don't have to go by any particular
recipe whether you know food or logical
recipe I could just create whatever I
want just a fun experience for the whole
family and it takes a little stress off
you for trying to meet those
expectations I can understand that what
about you also say don't bring baggage
from past bad thanksgivings if they
weren't fun start your own new tradition
so what are some of those ideas we can
allow ourselves to create a new
expression of the holidays Thanksgiving
could be a place where we incorporate a
new tradition like maybe we don't have
to go outside and play Touch football
maybe we don't have to sit down and
watch a parade maybe we could do
something like play charades or or get
out twister and and play that something
where we can create a new memory and
someone comes in my kitchen and offers
them all the yes go brew a pot of coffee
go empty the dishwater just dishwasher
go do something sweep the floors but the
cool thing about this is it can create
such a fun family memory like we're
having music blast in the kitchen
everyone's got assignments to do
everyone's enjoying being together it
like turns into a karaoke party and so
you can make cleanup part of the fun
memories and in the middle of the mess I
promise you that's where the most fun
memories are the mess that happens
outside that they bring inside that's
all over the tables everything and guess
what the whole family made the mess the
whole family can help clean it up and
even that's part of the fun okay great
to meet you you fun talking with you
happy holidays I have a feeling you're
not going to try too hard in your house
to have happy holidays they sound like a
lot of fun it's going to be fun all
right nice to meet you
thank you so much take care
well you know that lady's got a lot of
energy if she says seven kids and some
grandkids if you want to learn more
about Hannah you can check out her
website Hannah keely.com you can connect
with her on Facebook Instagram Twitter
Youtube Tick Tock she's all over the
social media that's what the trans kids
do yeah
that's cool they probably run her so
that's what I'm saying yeah that's the
thing